thank you
[Music]
so how many monies do you guys think it
would cost to build the Great Pyramid if
they were going to build it today whoa
today and you can't use any indentured
servitude or you cannot use the same
Union work if it's a union job then it's
a trillion oh my God if it's Union if
it's immigrant labor then it's probably
a billion
damn that's a [__] ton if it's union job
by the state of California then it will
probably be like the construction would
have been started and it would cost a
trillion and then they would like lose
the money and be like where did the
money go and it'll never get finished
and they didn't even build and they
didn't put a brick down yet that amount
of money would probably just go to the r
d to figure out how to build it you
don't have to do that first yeah wow and
then all the soft costs and the red tape
will never get to the actual like
sarcophagus in there yeah so check it
out the pyramid 756 feet long on each
side 700 481 feet high
2.3 million Stones weighing 3 tons each
whoa for a total mass of 6.5 million
tons holy [__] I'm gonna try to build it
today it would cost they're saying 5
billion wow which to me like Joe said
it seems like there's no corruption
involved
five billion five billion that's if
they've gave the contract of maybe
Legoland
they do you know what's funny yeah well
this is not funny it's kind of sad but
they spent like 10 billion on this rail
in Hawaii That was supposed to be
finished like a decade ago
it's the most 10 billion yeah it's it's
one of the most expensive rail projects
on Earth
and on Oahu it's like a mile long and
it's so [__] it's so bad a mile long
it's like [__] small it doesn't even
go to Waikiki or the airport it goes
from like the West Side to like this one
little stadium that they're gonna break
down anyway the corruption and the
incompetence is like [__]
mind-blowing Aloha Stadium right yeah I
think it's that one but they're shutting
they're gonna close that one down anyway
really yeah we're gonna have to swap it
looks like [__] in there have you seen
it I kind of like it did the did the
corrupt money from this project mainly
go to people not from Hawaii
we are I guess the state is going
through an audit through it and it's not
releasing [__] yet like did people come
in to work on it and take the money and
then bounce I think that's one of the
things that they're talking about
because like they said the cars were uh
they hired some Italian company to build
it not the Italian and then like sounds
Mafia to me right yeah and then like to
me I'm like Japan's like right there and
they're really [__] good at building
rails you know what Hawaii needs
Italians aren't known for their [__]
I'll tell you what Hawaii means
a [__] real
a monorail in California we try to do
remember the high-speed rail I voted for
it yeah exactly LA to [__] NorCal how
many billions did they did they eat up
for that just like and it disappears
disappeared didn't do it even derail
didn't even get completed nothing
happened it didn't no no it was [__]
dude we're all it's over we're all done
it's over
here the one that's going to Nevada the
Vegas one the it was I think it was
supposed to be the hyperlooper yeah yeah
I think um anisco's company bought it
but they've already done rail projects
and completed it bright line and they're
private so it's not government okay so
it's it sounds like it's more promising
are they already building it
um they're going to start either this
year or next year but they already have
a proof of concept I think in Orlando so
they've already built stuff yeah and
it's not government so it feels like
it's gonna actually happen um but I
think it's supposed to go from Vegas to
LA in two hours wow really and so you
get to just sit there and work which
makes my move to Las Vegas a little bit
more promising Colleen Summerlin yo dude
they built the original pyramid 4 000
workers over the course of 20 years 4
000 only that it was four thousand
that's what they estimate
with a piece of Rock
they use strength they use sleds
apparently they use ropes apparently
there's some methods we don't quite know
that they did because obviously those
are [__] huge huge Stones yeah
[__] cranes made by aliens we can't
get MythBusters
can't figure this out the posters can't
build a [__] pyramid Nick
well you know there's money would that
cost how about to lift like a three ton
rock you know they can't figure that
part MythBusters lost all credibility
when they did that McDonald's special
what was the McDonald's special for that
one McDonald's did a partnership with
MythBusters to show that McDonald's was
was making nuggets out of chicken no you
guys remember that yeah it was with that
Asian guy that passed away oh [__] they
did like a thing to uh to prove because
you know they wanted to clean up their
image do they know that people don't
care yeah people don't give a [__] I'll
just shovel that in my mouth go on there
they're not like that'll be authentic
[__] yeah who cares about how healthy
McDonald's is you're a [__] [__] if
you like go there and think that it
should be healthy if I if I buy chicken
nuggets and I opened it and I took a
bite
and it tasted like chicken and there's
like bone or whatever that gross me the
[__] out I'm pissed like if it tasted
like Wingstop it would gross me the [__]
out yeah imagine it's dark meat that
gross me the [__] out I'm like this is
where's that goo [__] it's supposed to
be sponges yeah
I want some [__] I want to chew into
a delicious eraser yeah
an eraser and mustard and then I want to
eat it yeah with chicken flavoring yeah
deep fried eraser
Elmer's Restaurant sauce did
um so if they did do the pyramids again
what feature would you want it to have a
basketball court basketball court at the
top oh [__] what happens if the ball
falls out oh no no no it's it's covered
rolls down you're
see when people would do uh like when
you go to Disneyland and they were like
Walt Disney built all these secret
compartments
and they had like diagrams I mean yeah
basketball court yeah but it's like
there's no way there's a [__]
basketball court there unless I'm the
[__] there is in the what Matterhorn
yeah it's a half court they do they said
they have a half court at the princess
castle Yeah
no they do they yeah they have actual
video footage of this yeah they have
real pictures I'm not buying them
Sleeping Beauty is capsule yep there's
even a jersey made out of her outfit
yeah but they should do something like
that in the pyramids because I feel like
what's in the pyramids now booby traps
and [__] no one's gone down there
nothing none of us no one's going down
there but apparently there was a tune
but they never found nobody's man see
the Titanic people that went down there
they should go check out the pyramids
that's what they should I think there's
a Halal Guys
it's just a cart but yeah like I've
always been curious of what's actually
there because I know that no one's
really good they're secret compartments
yeah there's like a bunch of like weird
hauls and [__] okay there's no document
or something there are it's they're just
boring really because the truth is
always boring yeah that's true it's
better to watch Indiana Jones people
think it was a power plant is that what
a power plant really that's that's the
new Theory because they're like
there's no there was it's like there's
no tomb there's no coffin there's
nothing there's no function well people
also think the pyramids are just the tip
of the infrastructure that it goes all
the way down oh yeah they say it goes
like this and it's actually a diamond we
can't start digging just a little bit
spoon dig yeah yeah then you could have
gone like a little bit and be like it
does go down yeah yo how sick if one day
that should just
[Laughter]
but the Egyptian government won't let
anybody wow well yeah they're like don't
[__] with our relics what about the the
Sphinx do people talk about that is that
still no one talks about that huh is
there no mystery around that's supposed
to be older than the pyramids apparently
same idea there's a theory about you dig
enough in the Sphinx is like the top of
some kind of structure too yeah it's
like the majority of the infrastructure
is actually all underground yeah that's
crazy it's a [__] hat it's a [__]
hat
and then it used to be a lion's face
yeah the [__] fell off right no then
they carved somebody else's face because
they're like a pharaoh was like looks
better if it was me
oh they've manually changed it yeah it
used to be Alliance that's one of the
things and then some time travelers were
like I remember when it was a lion's
face yeah
sometimes
but then they um real talk though
science talk so where the paws are
they're saying like um the reason why I
was older is because there's water
erosion around all of it and then
they're like oh this was during a time
when it was flooding and then the Nile
was here and all that but then the
pyramids don't have it so they're like
the Sphinx was probably here first
before the pyramids were built so it's
older than the pyramids do people think
the Sphinx is built by aliens too some
people if you watch Ancient Aliens
people think everything that's cool is
built by aliens yeah if it's cool and
it's old it's built by alien do you
think it's a cop-out
yep yeah
they're just saying there's no way
humans back then were smart enough and
I'm like and humans are always [__]
smart dude but dude as soon as we if you
know all this alien shit's happening
right now we're in the middle of all of
it if we do find that [__] out
I think some guys are gonna get dunked
on dude
that's true some of these Smarties are
gonna get dunked on dude what about
sucralose you think what's the name
George sukulos do you think he's gonna
be like rubbing everyone's face the guy
that did aliens guys yeah this guy you
think he's gonna just dunk on everyone I
think he's gonna need a whole Clause of
the basketball shoes but what if we
asked the aliens we're like did you guys
build those or they're like no it's
whack we think that's just whack you
guys so then he can't really slam dunk
so like we think the that looks like
[__] yeah and you guys love talking
about it you guys will go visit it you
guys think you're so cool you guys go
visit it all the time take little
pictures of it
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]